this is agent 20 21.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so i'm super excited like obviously i do
this a ton but it's never been
my party right i've just been a guest
the maybe the guest of honor
but always just a guest and so to be the
host and kim is crushing it
and the venue's insane uh hopefully you
or drock or somebody will get
some sort of crazy angle from up top
like it's pretty [ __ ] legit
and uh everything is perfect uh and i'll
you know just because i love steve ross
i will not razz on the dolphins part of
it all
the irony of it all but uh super excited
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage the ceo of vaynerx
gary vaynerchuk
you know when i when i came up with the
concept of the name
i thought it was interesting to create a
conference that actually expires
we our ambition is to create
this brand agent 2021 for people that we
have as agents you know obviously we
pick the four sectors
industries that i think what i'm about
to keynote about really matter
the timing around my new book crushing
it and
and this talk is very important because
what is stunning to me
is how much opportunity there is for
everybody at this conference
what i think is super important to
to really attack this morning is
i truly believe that most of you don't
understand how big the stakes are
because you get caught the way i get
caught i don't believe
that most of us understand how early it
is and i'm worried that you haven't gone
deep enough
while you're thinking about going wider
you're doing well
on facebook ads or google ads but you're
leaving
so much more on the table i know this
because even i'm doing that if i could
give you the biggest piece of advice
that would be blanket that i know
everybody could be affected by
whether you have a restaurant or did
whether you have a liquor store or did
whether you're in the real estate
business insurance i know for fact
for fact that you could 4-50
times x your investment in both creative
the pictures the videos the written
words and in actually spending the ads
to get far more the fact that you're
spending and it's working
is hiding the fact that there's a lot
more underneath that
and i would really really really take
advantage of this morning to set
up to set up the mindset for you to
realize
there's probably a lot more going on in
the depth than there is in the width
before you get inspired to start your
show your podcast your alexa skill
what's going on with vine 2 when it
comes out
before you do that which you should but
i feel like for most of us
including myself that should be 20
of our energy and mind and 80
should be looking very carefully at
what's working
and getting far more committed to it
this moment right now this is how it's
going to play out and i'm putting it on
film
and i'll look back at it this is the
land grab
of the internet this is the land grab to
establish yourself
as the personality the authority the
organization
the service in your industry still you
could have four competitors
who've got more followers than you you
can have people you look up to that have
crushed it
and things of that nature that will
speak today but still
we haven't even come close so what does
this all mean
here's how i think this plays out i
genuinely believe that 80 percent
and that includes people that are more
shy and scared to be on camera
and are introverted i believe that 80 of
this audience
over the next half decade is gonna start
debating having a drock
and an iris and a babin i think all of
you
over the next decade will realize that
you are in the media business
that before that you are any kind of
agent you are actually a show
that the [ __ ] that you watch on bravo
and hgtv and all the other [ __ ]
channels
you could do the same thing outside of
the guy we have here in his show and
about three other shows
nobody really watches any of these cable
shows literally the biggest thing that's
holding back the far majority of this
room
from going to a completely different
level financially and happy wise
is the fact that every year they're just
taking home too much of the money they
made
and they're buying cars and vacations
and homes
and [ __ ] [ __ ] jewelry if you're
making money right now
please reinvest it in the one thing that
doesn't get shattered
during a bad economy which is your
reputation
i can't thank you enough for being here
i am so excited about agent 2021
i'm so humbled that you guys are here i
adore you and i'm really looking forward
to seeing you guys throughout the rest
of the day
thank you
thank you for that that was like a
game-changer listen
it's it's the point of this whole talk
if like honestly while i've got a lot of
you listening because this is a
different
feeling than on stage listen to me
nobody here is spending enough money or
time
on this thing nobody if i'm not you're
not even [ __ ] close
nobody there's so much for you to take
and i just think everybody's checking
the box
you feel good that you're on it when
you're with your other friends
because you have a couple like you
justify things like i have 4 000
followers on instagram it means dick
like you have to go all in this is like
well i can feel the regret building in
my own body
and i'm like literally the leader of the
whole [ __ ] thing so where the [ __ ]
are you
please please understand how big this is
yeah just one little different tone
today vlog just like
just kind of talk to everybody like i
would talk to like one person a lot of
time i'm in showman mode
i went way more mellow just like please
i was like
almost pleading like right it was like a
plea and it's a plea to all of you like
please
understand how great this era is we're
just not going hard enough
[ __ ] thank you brother
it's the internet my friends it's the
[ __ ] internet
it's not him or me it's the internet it
eliminates
everything that is commodity this is
about the [ __ ] internet and it's
gonna [ __ ] break your face
unless you ride the wave because too
many of you are looking at the wave
coming at you
and you think you're somebody because
you've had some success this thing is
gonna [ __ ] kill you amen
i uh i really am concerned that people
think that they're doing social media
and marketing and building their
personal brand
and i think that that concerns me
because i think that there's so much
left to be had
i think good enough is just a bad idea
always because you're not pushing
yourself
and taking it there i think what i'm
even specifically focused on right now
is
there's underpriced attention on social
media that can be leveraged
for your success for your happiness and
so what i was kind of ranting at since
the people that came to this conference
are a little bit more educated is
hey i know that you have an instagram
and a facebook account i know you're
running some of these ads
you're doing google you're getting it
but let's gear it up deeper let's do
more facebook ads let's do a podcast
let's get serious because the land grab
is real
and the tough thing about real estate is
you don't know who's in the market
so you need brand awareness you are
trading on brand that is what re max and
[ __ ] you know and all the other doug
element that's
its brand when ryan was like they're not
gonna matter i'm like brand always
matters
brand always matters so it's good to own
it not rent it
every one of you is wearing something
right now far more likely because of the
brand
not because of the sales i don't think
you walked into a store and got
sold those sneakers you came you knew
what you you know like
you knew brand brand
what's that the cheese whistles that's
exactly right
how come we didn't give us all a pair
because they're sold the [ __ ] out
two hours man anyway gotta go let's go
we had everybody on facebook live
live what up love you guys see ya see
you all right bye guys see you soon
thank you thank you man
thank you brother what's your overall
message not just today but when you
macro 400 trillion to one
was my overall message i just can't
believe i'm looking right at you camera
that we don't take advantage of the fact
that we're people like it's 400 trillion
to one to even become a person
my overall message is to squeeze this
thing for all it's got
and hey the internet has come along and
for everybody who's sitting and watching
this right now and is in a job that they
hate
the fact that they can still pay their
mortgage their college
loans or their kids schools but then
from 7 p.m to 2 in the morning
sell stuff on ebay start a vlog start a
podcast this is real
this is very real people can say oh
it's real i came from nothing and
millions of people have come from
nothing on the back of the internet
loaded question what is the truth about
college
for children are you going to pay for
his college
yes i am well then take your four-year
vacation bro
[Applause]
i mean look look i think look this the
the the
the college thing is very very very
difficult for me i wish i actually was a
great student i wish i went to harvard
because i think i could impact more
people i think most people think my
point of view on college
is because i was a [ __ ] student and went
to a [ __ ] college and became successful
my point of view on college is based on
unemotional math
the math is broken we went through a 50
60 year period where going to college
was roi positive
if you went to college and got a piece
of paper you would then be able to get
the return on that investment
because that's how the world worked and
we were in the era of corporations
having the control that does not exist
do you need do you need a degree for
certain professions if you want to be a
doctor lawyer
i understand all that but
college is will he become a well-rounded
young man
and like all the social things let him
go tour [ __ ] europe for three months
he'll be way more well-rounded and
worldly than sitting in a [ __ ] dorm
room playing [ __ ] call of duty
and we just won the war in our house
thank you you're welcome
love you guys see ya like literally for
the last probably a year now i would say
i've been dreaming about this call
there's not been anything
that is gonna disrupt marketing to the
level of
that voices uh since social and so i'm
just excited to be at the forefront of
it
yeah where'd this whole idea come about
agent 2021 i heard there was you're
going to love this
okay agent 2021 yes a recap
of this amazing event here's what i
could tell it's going well
we're in the middle of it right now for
a first time event
it's grand right it's like a stadium
like
i think my team did an incredible job
i'm sure we'll recap
some of the strengths some of the
weaknesses here's what i can tell you
the 2019 version of this event
is going to be pretty gangster a tip of
advice to all these audiences that would
you know like see you and it's like a
role model stuff
patience [ __ ] patience
patience and self-esteem that's what i
give a [ __ ] about
i guess my punch line is this next
generation is going to destroy
destroy 40 to 50 of the establishment
because that establishment didn't know
how to speak to them but now these kids
live
100 on their phone yep which means that
if you're not in
instagram and snapchat you don't exist
yeah brands that are growing
at an extreme rapid rate are spending on
facebook and instagram
and brands that are declining at an
extreme rapid rate
are disproportionately spending money on
television there's nothing else to say
that's data it's just it's just about
perspective on this [ __ ]
yeah you have no choice
absolutely what are you gonna dwell
about two thousand [ __ ] eight
for how long you won't get your [ __ ]
together unless you understand what the
[ __ ] is actually happening here
and what's actually happening here is
we're living through the greatest
[ __ ] time of all time because
we are [ __ ] live on video on faith
do you guys understand how ridiculous
the opportunity is
please take advantage of it so many
people wasting the opportunity
because you taste a little success and
you're not really [ __ ] squeezing my
whole keynote this morning was a weird
vibe i was like
i was like we're not we're not [ __ ]
squeezing it enough [ __ ] squeeze it
canada
[Music]
you're welcome take care bye guys
congratulations
guys congrats but i feel like the cooler
thing for me to see throughout the day
was like that
created this and it got people here but
the value that they got
out of what we provided and then they
left and they were like you guys
the core of what people felt about what
you guys did and then what our
employees did it was great all right
thank you guys bye
just another day at the office
[Music]
future
my why is really like gratitude almost
guilt
i feel like i was gifted all this [ __ ]
and i feel like i give back right
i i can get you okay 100 is that really
what gets you up like
100 legacy
[Music]
what do you think that someone can do to
add as much value so one thing i'm
fascinated by with realtors
is the recall if i told the three of you
four of you
my favorite my favorite move my favorite
move
i i think you guys sell a home and
you're and you're out
it's like you hooked up with the pretty
girl and you're out i think if you went
and sent somebody a 200 gift basket
18 months not a year after you sold
their home and said hey
thinking about you so hoping that you're
in love with the homeless you were a
year and a half ago
that's it that they're gonna get that
gift basket and be like
the [ __ ] and then three weeks later
their aunt's gonna come over and say
they're selling a home and they say you
know who you [ __ ] have to use
no when i tell you nobody does it for
real
[Applause]
he still has a voice
i don't know how much voice i have but i
will say this first of all
i want to thank tom for coming out ryan
i see you in the corner there
your hair is getting a little puffier
which i like
it's the humidity i knew it i want to
thank you too bro and your whole team
i mean your whole team's got gray hair
uh
i uh thank you guys all so much for
coming out
you know you guys being here has given
our team back home
an obnoxious amount of confidence of
what we're going to do with this next
year
i want to just thank everybody for
coming out i think there was a lot of
value today
most of all i hope you heed the content
that you consumed
there's a lot of winners in this room
and i think winners are the most
vulnerable
because they're leaving a lot on the
table because they're winning
and so i hope that's the theme that a
lot of people left with but most of all
just thank you so much i wish you guys
help because everything else is
controllable
i love you more bro uh and uh thanks for
being here and i hope you have a good
night
take care thanks cheers
you